ما بين الامس واليوم يعود سجل الهجمات على
البعثات الاجنبيه في ايران مع مقتل مسؤول
جهاز الامن في سفاره اذربيجان بالعاصمه
طهران في هجوم المسلح وصفات هوباكو
بالارهابي ولاحقا اخلد اذربيجان سفاراتها
في طهران واجلت كامل الفريق الدبلوماسي من
ايران محمله طبعا النظام الايراني
المسؤوليه الكامله عن الهجوم المسلح ولعل
مشاهدينا هذه الحادثه تؤكد تخصص سهران في
ترهيب الدبلوماسيين الاجانب في السياق
طبعا التوتر الذي يطرا على علاقات طهران
والمجتمع الدولي هجمات ارتفع مستواها خلال
العقود الاربعه الماضيه وفقه معارضين
ومواقع ايرانيه علقوا على الحادثه الاخيره
بانها تعكس مدى هشاشه النظام الايراني في
علاقاته الديبلوماسيه
ويبقى هؤلاء مدفوعين من الحرس الثوري
والانظمه التي حصلت همم لا تزال طبعا في
حقبتها الهجمات على السفارات على مدى
العقل هنا نعود لاسوا حادثه في تاريخ
الهجمات على السفارات والقنصليات التي
تعود الى اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه في
نوفمبر من العام 1979 على يد مجموعه من
المتشددين من انصار الخميني بعد فتره
قصيره من سقوط الشاه يومها اختطف موالوا
النظام 52 امريكيا وغالبيتهم طبعا
دبلوماسيين
يوما تم احتجازهم حتى تم اطلاق سراحهم في
20 من يناير من العام 1981 حيث طبعا
طالبوا همم طالب منفذوه العمليه الولايات
المتحده بتسليم الشاه رضا بهلوي لتتم
محاكمه الشاه في ايران مقابل الافراج عن
الرهائن وهو الذي لم يحصل طبعا
ايران تاريخ من الاعتداءات على السفارات
والبعثات دبلوماسيه عام
1979 اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه بتهران
واحتجاز رهائن امريكيين لمده 444 يوما عام
1987 اعتداء على مقر السفاره السعوديه في
طهران عام
1988 متظاهرون يهاجمون السفاره الاتحاد
السوفيتي حينها عام 2009 متظاهرون
ايرانيون يهاجمون السفاره الباكستانيه في
طهران 2011 اقتحام السفاره البريطانيه بعد
فرض عقوبات بسبب برنامج نووي عام 2016